welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the breaker of
news Lord of the leaks and now I don't
get too involved in this whole woke
debate that happens on the Internet
this is a story that I just had to cover
because it's pretty hilarious so we are
now getting a report slowly starting to
circulate that the reason that HBO
decided to cancel the prequel to their
highly successful Game of Thrones series
was because the show was apparently -
woke this comes from bizarre TV editor
Annie halls who earlier this week stated
that the G ot show was axed because HBO
was too worried that the show would get
a lot of backlash due to its changing of
certain aspects of the source material
the show was reportedly going to feature
the first white Walker as a black man
but lesbian characters at the center of
the plot and make ned stark's ancestors
mixed race which worried HBO execs that
there would be a lot of backlash
whenever things like this happened I
always think that there's no real reason
that they're doing this other than to
take foxes and I've actually sat in
marketing meetings before where they've
said diversity is a good tactic to get
people interested now I don't want to
get too far into the politics behind it
but if you look at Disney they are
clearly pushing at the moment to show
how inclusive and how much they care
about equality every film they do at the
moment has a big push about how diverse
of a cast there is but they clearly
don't practice what they preach when you
see how they market things like Star
Wars and black panther in China where
black characters aren't very popular
it's very apparent they are only doing
this entire inclusive thing for money
they shrunk pin down on the force
awakens poster and covered black panther
up so this whole we want to push
diversity thing is very vague to me this
is just my opinion across the board in
Hollywood and I want to see them do some
actual changes rather than just
pretending that they care anyway HBO are
kind of treading water at this point
with many fans being disappointed by the
finale of season 8 of Game of Thrones
and they're being petitions made to
refilm the ending create a 9th season
and have D&D Eden by dragons HBO put
thirty million dollars into the first
episode of the prequel and still decided
at the last minute that it wasn't worth
pursuing which to me is absolutely crazy
like how was this not ironed out in the
passing process so that they didn't
waste all that time and money we don't
know but it seems like we won't be
getting any walk walkers on screen
anytime soon now what I think has
happened is that HBO decided to go ahead
with the pilot because whilst it was in
the production phase they didn't really
seem like there was any anti walk agenda
on the Internet this started getting
made three years ago and this was a time
when studios were really trying to push
as hard as possible to appear inclusive
and accepting of everything even if an
outcry said that it wasn't true to the
source material naturally HBO wanted to
jump on the bandwagon of this but as of
late we know that this can often
backfire with a lot of movies that put
politics before plot flopping
commercially and being labeled as studs
that are trying too hard to please as
many people as possible ultimately
pleasing no one it's one of the big main
reasons that I think Terminator doc fate
is flopped and there was a big push in
the marketing especially on director Tim
Miller side to show how progressive the
film was he said that the film would
scare the crap out of closeted
misogynists and it got tons and tons of
coverage and retweets
in hindsight though it's clear that
these people haven't turned up to the
cinema because the movie is set to lose
over 100 million dollars Terminator
won't break even and considering it has
absolutely no competition right now at
the cinema this is a big sign of how
much public interest there actually is
in properties you don't need to be brand
the broken to see that pretty much 90%
of the time when a beloved franchise is
taken and injected with an agenda it
flops we see this all the time with
female at films such as oceans 8 the
kitchen ghostbusters annihilation where
people online say that they want to see
this they say that it's time that
Hollywood did something like this and
then they don't actually go to the
movies annihilation is really good by
the way so yeah if you haven't seen that
then definitely do anyway I think HBO is
kind of reading the writing on the wall
and they realize that they don't want to
score political points if it's gonna
annoy the audience personally I don't
really care as long as a story is good
but I'm kind of sick of going through
the whole media cycle of them announcing
a quote-unquote work show then one
person on line saying it sucks the media
then embellishing on that and say
online trolls are bashing the show when
there's only about three people doing it
what then happens is the show does okay
and then the media go ahead with
headlines such as this shows sexist that
they are wrong it happens over and over
again and yet if we can skip that then
I'm absolutely over the moon thirty
million dollars is a lot to lose so
clearly HBO were really reading the
terrain here and the show which was
reportedly going to tackle colonialism
would likely just feel too heavy-handed
for fans who just want to show about
dragons and people having sex with their
sisters the series which was being run
by writer and producer Jane Goldman who
was married to Jonathan Ross has worked
on the show for over three years and in
its cancellation HBO announced a new
prequel called House of the Dragon which
is said to be more similar to the
original series which yeah smart move I
don't know why you weren't doing that in
the first place
bizarre TV said that their sauce stated
that HBO were terrified the first
prequel would scare hardcore fans it was
very different to the original series
but was very brave and bold plainly it
was too ambitious for bosses who thought
in my alien 8 viewers the talk is that
the new script is very average but
deemed a safe option which year after
the final season it may be best to play
it safe because D&D kind of ruined their
reputation of it and though we haven't
had any confirmation on this you can bet
season 8 of Game of Thrones was a big
factor that played into the reason that
they exited the Star Wars project look
yeah Lucasfilm have fired so many
directors at this point you can't really
blame them and they probably got cold
feet over the finale the source then
went on to say that the prequel was very
woke and subversive but they've decided
to go for a script by a bloke and full
of dragons they've missed an open goal
to do something different
spending more than 30 million and three
years has been a monumental waste of
time and money there's a lot of angry
people so yeah I do kind of agree with
that latter part it is a lot of money
and time wasted but looking at some of
the online backlash towards Watchmen and
so on
you can see why they axe the idea of a
work prequel instead of just the idea of
a prequel I kind of don't agree with
their they've missed an open goal to do
something different statement because
fans most of the time they don't want
anything different and in fact in the
case of the last Jedi they
often get really angry when something is
done that they don't view in line with
their beloved property now one thing
that this might be highlighting is that
there is slowly starting to be a tone in
Hollywood where they finally finally
realized that fans don't want political
messages shoved down their throat we
don't care if you tick boxes we know
this is pandering to appeal to as many
people as possible and just stop it
things can be inclusive and exclusive
and still be fine I don't care about
little women it's not made for me I
don't care about Downton Abbey it's not
made for me I don't mind being excluded
from it these things shouldn't determine
the quality of something but when that's
the main talking point over the actual
plot of the story it becomes clear that
this is just a marketing strategy use it
drum up interest there are properties
that just seem to be doing it to win
round a very vocal minority that don't
put their money where their mouth is I
when shows films and so on actually ask
them to turn up and support the projects
they don't I mean look at the films I
mentioned before if you looked online it
would seem like these were gonna be home
runs with everyone crying out for them
however in the end no one want to see
them I'm gonna put a bed on right now
that Charlie's Angels bombs juxtaposing
this the Joker was getting lambasted
left right and center and so many people
were screaming outrage about how violent
that the movie was gonna be and still
people piled in in droves to see it to
the point where it's now actually been
more profitable than infinity war and
will likely hit the billion dollar mark
very soon I think
HBO I've just finally realized that
people don't actually go and watch this
stuff and all it does is turn fans off
you should never a lien eight your core
audience and that is something that so
many studios get wrong in their
marketing when they try and attract a
new demographic they put down their fans
in order to attempt to get new people on
board that don't really care and thus
the project ends up falling very short
I'm kind of glad that they realized this
and decided to cancel that because by
the sounds of it all it was going to do
was in my fans who don't want or need to
see this stuff in their entertainment
The Twilight Zone is a perfect example
for me like I absolutely loved the
original but the messages in the new one
even though I agree with them was so
heavy-handed that they just had me
rolling my eyes you're preaching to the
choir and don't need to be and thank God
HBO decided that playing it safe
aiming things towards the audience that
likes
shows is the smart thing to do hopefully
this new show house of the Dragon is
more in line with what people want
because honestly that's all I want as
well I know in the final season of Game
of Thrones that has slammed the show
pretty badly but that's because I was so
invested in it my criticisms came
because I loved it so much it was just
sad seeing what it turned into you
it's the same with terminator and why
that movie disappointed me so yeah hats
off to HBO for doing this it is a pretty
hilarious reason to give well maybe we
will finally start to see a shift in
Hollywood where they go back to
marketing movies for being movies
instead of for what messages they are
carrying someone's sexual orientation
race beliefs they don't matter to me
so why they made such a big deal in a
show like this answer is because
corporations think it will make their
money if we really want to be inclusive
then we should be making these kind of
casting decisions naturally without
having to pat ourselves on the back for
it look at the matrix in 1999 that had a
really diverse cast and not once was
they brought up in the marketing and
that was 20 years ago it's the Hollywood
equivalent of smelling your own thoughts
and I'm glad that we are getting beyond
it and going back to focusing on what
people love I'm sure the people behind
the show the heart were in the right
place but this doesn't create unity it
creates division and is a dumb marketing
tactic so yeah I'm glad they pulled the
plug now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news and if you think
it indicates it in in Hollywood or if
you want to see more work shows coming
out comment below and let me know and if
you enjoy this video then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
my breakdown of HBO's watch them in
which would be linked at the end we go
over everything that you need to know
about the show so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which would be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
boxer on blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning it's like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the cancellation in the comments section
the winners gonna be chosen the 15th of
November and the set will be shipped out
from them - ever gets the prize - best
of luck to everyone he takes part this
is a channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]